the full trailer for The One Piece live
action series on Netflix is finally here
and oh boy we do have to look at it
because within the first three minutes
we got a closer look at a ton of stuff
including most of the major characters
the rough outline of the plots the
fighting the CGI and even one major
change to the main storyline and I'm
just gonna say it right out of the gate
after watching this trailer about 50
times now this actually looks pretty
damn great like I'm genuinely excited to
see the show now and I'm blown away that
this actually looks so promising after I
was honestly a little bit torn about the
initial teaser it feels really weird but
and yes of course there was gonna be a
but there were of course also going to
be some things that really rubbed me the
wrong way and I still want to discuss
that as well starting in order of the
trailer with the execution of the pirate
king Goldie Roger and first of all and
this often goes unnoticed in production
but I really do appreciate the sound
design of this opening sequence here the
sound of the boots the chains the gears
clanking and then the sound of the blade
rushing down when they're about to
execute Roger like great sound design
just can Elevate The Experience so so
much and make it so much easier to
immerse yourself into a new world and by
the way I also really love the design of
Rogers Jolly Roger on the back of his
code in this shot right here now the
next thing that really really blew me
away here is the set design of a loc
town the city this takes place in like
holy hell this looks so much better than
I could have ever imagined like hands
down this might actually be my favorite
set in the entire show so far next to of
course baratier although there will be
one set i'm personally particularly very
unhappy with but we'll get to that in
just a moment also and again this is
subtle but has major impact on how we
see a show is the color grading here
like the washed out yellowy tone with
muted Blues really gives this exact Vibe
I was hoping for it does give this scene
such a great ambient textury feel that
really tells me that this happens in a
world roughly equal to the Victorian era
and we also have our first subtle change
to the original anime because the
producers actually changed the looks of
the executioners a little bit here in my
opinion actually very much to the better
while the two faceless characters here
in the original manga don't exactly look
super threatening I really dig the
costumes that they designed for the live
adaptation here in other words these
guys do look like they do mean business
and yet another change that I majorly
approve of is having GARP being present
at raja's execution here I mean this
makes sense not only because it
introduces us to Luffy's grandfather
being a high-ranking marina right from
the start but also because he was
Roger's rival and at some point friends
who took in his secret son Ace and it
also adds for me to the scene at
marineford where GARP is sitting next to
Ace I mean if he had to be at Major
executions like this one with Roger it
would make it even more painful for garb
having to be at the execution of two of
the people that he really respected and
cared for Father and Son no less or if
he was actually there voluntarily it
would mean that Garb chose to show
respect and be there to support both
Roger and Ace so whatever it really is I
actually do love this change and kind of
wish that it happened the original story
as well and also let's be real they
absolutely nailed GARP here like you
knew right away who this man was which
actually now brings me to two things I
didn't really like so much which
actually is the man himself here Roger
now don't get me wrong they did
absolutely get the clothing perfect and
the voice acting is actually fantastic
but I really somehow don't Vibe with the
casting here for some reason like I
don't think we knew about this person
and nothing against this guy again I do
love his voice performance but neither
The Voice nor the face just scream Roger
to me like even the mustache looks kind
of out of place in this face here and I
do know that there are people who would
have absolutely rocked this role there
was actually a rumor around that Jack
Black might be going to play Roger which
of course would have been absolutely
legendary I will say though that I do
love the detail of him having these
yellow teeth because that is exactly the
level of realism that I do miss a little
bit from some of the other scenes here
and the second thing that I do not
really like here is actually the crowd
work we see now obviously background
acting and crowd acting is a little bit
of an ungrateful job sometimes and there
is barely a lot of camera time on anyone
specifically anyways but the people that
they do show here in the crowd or like
the woman running with the swords I mean
maybe I'm just being a little bit too
harsh but they don't really sell to me
that these are real people in a real
world they do feel more like someone
just screamed action and then they just
went but really it's a bit of a minor
complaint so moving on to Luffy leaving
his home Island which is called on
island in the manga in case you don't
know on a tiny boat with no idea how to
navigate 8 looking out at Sea saying
that he wants to get a crew now clearly
this is what the joke here with the
seagull is referencing from the manga
which by the way is called a news coup
and is part of the newspaper delivery
system in the one piece world and while
it didn't appear in the original manga I
actually absolutely loved how it turned
out here I actually can't quite tell 100
if this is CGI or a puppet but it does
look perfectly real to me and I do
wonder what type of news it might bring
Luffy that we actually didn't get in the
original story I actually think it might
serve as an introduction or Exposition
for some characters like maybe Zorro or
arlong though as far as I know we don't
even know if Luffy can actually read in
the anime and now coming back to the
joke itself though this is something
that I already was clear of during the
teaser trailer but we're clearly gonna
get a lot of these very marvel-esque
one-liner jokes here that I personally
just don't find super funny but I can
live with them and so it is what it is
also in this case honestly it even work
somewhat to me because because Luffy
would probably be the type of person who
would have actually invited a seagull
into the crew in the manga if he had
landed on the boat at this moment well
also I'm not gonna play any music of
course for copyright reasons but the
track that starts playing right
afterwards like that sounds a little bit
ripped off from Pirates of the Caribbean
right am I right I'm not imagining this
I can't get kind of a weird choice I
mean I'd rather would have preferred a
more visual nod to that series by making
things look less clean and more real but
hey we do get the iconic Luffy in a
barrel scene though however he managed
to get in there which I'm actually
really looking forward to seeing him
explode out of there in front of Kobe
which actually brings us right to
alvida's ship right here which is in the
process of plundering some other poor
pirate ship and I love it like the fact
that they actually show a somewhat
realistic Pirate Battle with people
swinging on ropes and cannons being
fired something that is even missing a
little bit from the original show so to
me this real really helps me sell this
world especially considering that we're
still in the East blue here where things
like Devil fruits and hockey are
insanely rare and most people don't even
know that they are a real thing I also
think that alvita's ship design is
really cool here actually better than
the going Mary in my opinion where this
sheep's head still kind of haunts my
dreams I don't understand why they
didn't go with the original here and
alvita herself is all right I guess like
the casting and costume is great but she
almost doesn't look uh mean enough here
if you know what I mean so that might
just end up being fine in the final
series also for some reason here the
pirate ships do actually look dirty edgy
and very real just what I was hoping for
but then so many other sets like the
Mary itself or the costumes of so many
of the characters like the straw hats or
the Marines just looks so damn clean I
mean here look at those dirty sails with
holes in them now that's what I would
have loved for everything in the show
and I'll be honest I'm not really sure
what the red explosion in the next shot
here is but it does look visually very
stunning so I'm very excited to see it
in the show and find out what that is
and then the Jolly Roger reveal and even
though there is some somewhat corny
dialogue here once again I really
couldn't help but grin seeing this
because they took the exact design from
the manga which I do really appreciate
and actually I do really buy the acting
for Luffy here as well also a small fun
fact the first person in the manga to
actually say the phrase Straw Hat
Pirates is actually not Luffy but the
Marine Captain smoker way later during
the alabaster Arc so this is not an
official term but I of course don't mind
at all that it's Luffy here who gives
the straw hats their name and then we
get a bit of a traveling Montage which
really sets up the goal of reaching the
grand line which I strongly assume will
be the conclusion of this first season
reaching reverse Mountain because
entering the grand line and then meeting
laboon would in my opinion made a
perfect first episode for a season two
basically kicking off the entire
Alabaster Saga next and I'm not really
sure whose shift is this that is
capsizing here in that shot in the waves
on the grand line but it does look
awesome as heck and then we get a first
look at buggy circus hand which I also
think did turn out awesome in fact buggy
his crew and the set make them seem way
more of a threat I think than their
original appearances in the manga and
next we have mihawk mihawk himself
basically is as perfect as I could have
ever dreamed it Steven Ward here is just
perfect for this role the costume is
Flawless and even the colored contacts
work perfectly here with the little ring
the fight scene with Zara the baratier
is bound to be one of the biggest
highlights of the show and yet why does
the sword here look like it's made out
of plastic I mean yoro in this close-up
just looks like some low budget
merchandise toy that you can buy and
it's just such a shame I mean I mean
yeah making any big crazy anime weapon
look real is very very difficult but
there are whole YouTube channels out
there doing exactly that I mean for
comparison just look at the version of
your that the craft Channel Army made
eight years ago and how awesome that
looks next up though we have a really
short scene with Captain kuro's claws
appearing behind Mary Kaya's Butler from
usob's home Island and yeah he's
actually called Mary because he's the
one who built the original going Mary
and apparently named the ship after
himself very humble also this is just a
fantastic little teaser for this Arc
here and Kudo will be a super fun
villain to see in the live action as
well I think with his massive claw hands
that we actually get to see a little bit
later again boring into the floor next
to Luffy and then we have a shot of
Zorro in a well for some reason and yes
this trailer sadly uh confirmed
something that I was a little bit
worried about with the teaser as well
and this might be a very controversial
take uh here it is I'm just not buying
Zorro as a character here like don't get
me wrong makenu looks like the perfect
Zoro the fight scenes look perfectly
like Zorro but the dialogue and the way
that he talks sorry that for me that
that's just not Zorro I mean yeah he's
supposed to be cool but what makes him
so unique and likable is also these
comedic moments when he actually lets
that cool facade slip and how much he
really cares about Luffy and the entire
crew and I'm really sorry but to me
that's just not what I'm getting out of
here at all which is just such a shame
because he is one of my absolute
favorite characters in one piece and we
even get to see zoro's oath through
Luffy which is also quite altered from
the original manga scene I mean there it
happens with Zoros just being cut open
after losing to mihawk and almost
drowning bawling his eyes out which is
one of the few emotional moments that
make Zorro so awesome and I might be
wrong and we still get that scene as it
happens but if this here turns out to be
the actual oath scene again I'm just not
buying it that that's not enough emotion
in that for me at all but now moving on
to something that does look just
incredible we have buggy and his powers
and they do look awesome I was really
worried but the cgi4's powers absolutely
work this set as I mentioned is epic as
well and this will absolutely also go
down as one of the highlights of the
first season I think he looks like a
fantastic villain here can't wait to see
the goofy parts of it as well but great
job and this now brings us to what is
clearly going to be the actual climax of
this first season the fight against the
Fishman Pirates which interestingly
enough seems to be set up at the
baratier and this will of course be
probably the single biggest change to
the original because it does seem here
like Don Creek the main villain of the
baratia arc has been replaced by arlong
and his men who might be there to take
back Nami by force maybe instead of Nami
betraying the crew and while this might
end up being a controversial Choice it
might actually work out in their favor
as long as they make sure that they get
these three things right number the one
mihawk still needs his epic entrance
cutting a ship in half and I doubt that
he will be sinking arlong's ship then we
still need to see sanji's kindness which
was basically him giving food to the
starving gin in the manga who then
turned out to be an enemy and then
thirdly Nami nods of betraying slash
leaving the crew on her own Accords
would actually be a quite dramatic
change to her character Arc and her
Redemption later on in the story when
she then fully trusts slothy to save her
and her Village however that being said
if they actually managed to work all of
these things in I really don't hate the
idea of setting up the Fishman as the
final villains of the season a little
bit earlier here and just leaving gin
and Don Creek aside also and I can't
stop stressing this enough the baratia
set is by far the most epic thing in
this entire trailer for me that I just
love so so much it just looks so damn
fantastic that it's obvious that they
really really went above and beyond to
design this and I am all here for it
which now now sadly I cannot say the
same thing about arlong Park as well
because honestly to me again this just
looks like Disneyland Fake Plastic rocks
to me I'm really sorry like the main
building itself the tower it looks great
both on the inside and on the outside
you can actually see nami's maps in
there and also when it collapses that
does look incredibly real to me but the
yard in front of it where the fighting
happens again I just don't buy the
location it's it kind of feels like
mihawk sword a little bit too fake
however again what does look very much
promising very very promising is the
fighting choreography here like all the
non-cgi character Powers look incredible
zoro's sword skills sanji's kicks who
stop sniping they all look fantastic and
and I'm glad to see that there will
actually be blood in this show as well
as we see Zorro just ruthlessly slashing
someone's heel here this actually makes
me very confident that the actual fight
scenes might end up being an incredible
joy to watch and Luffy CGI that we see
him stretching the face just like in the
manga here and then his Gatling gun are
actually as perfect as you could
possibly have made it for a power that
feels almost impossible to bring to life
in a live-action setting so for that
really uh heads off to the showrunners
for this because I do 100 buy Luffy here
which I honestly did not think was
possible at the beginning now arlong on
the other hand ah I mean same thing here
it was always going to be very hard to
bring the actual fishermen to life
properly but it's just it just doesn't
look right to me here I mean I wonder if
maybe dropping the long nose like I did
with usop might have been a wiser Choice
here but even then yeah I don't know I
just it just looks it just feels off
kind of from what we get in the manga
now the scene of Luffy giving his Straw
Hat tsunami which next to Zorro's oath
is probably the best scene in the entire
East blue Saga in the original manga
could really go either way the way it
looks right here now to be honest I
don't quite feel the heaviness of the
scene like in the original here but it's
just a very quick snippet from a trailer
with upbeat epic music so it might end
up being just perfectly fine in the show
with a lot more context and the right
music and then both Shanks and the Sea
King they just look absolutely awesome
very excited to see also how shanks's
lines and his delivery will be like but
this already looks great as does the
iconic giving Luffy his Straw Hat scene
though I do think that background
framing could have been a little bit
cleaner maybe have the ocean in the
background but still it does look very
nice then we see a quick shot of Morgan
and his accent again looking very
promising and boy Kobe here is just Kobe
like this is as perfect as it gets
dialogue costume everything this is Kobe
and we do get three little Easter eggs
actually in the bouncy poster that Luffy
looks at all from pirates that Luffy
will meet in the grand line with Bellamy
from skypeia foxy who set up the Davey
backfight and Cavendish who joined
Luffy's Grand Fleet Andres Rosa and I do
kind of hope that uh these are little
hints that we might be seeing these
people in later seasons and that we get
more seasons in general but I don't
really dig the delivery of the king of
the Pirates line at the end like that's
not quite Luffy for me but that might
just be my personal taste here however
while I do have a couple of issues like
this one with Luffy right here overall
this live action might actually turn out
to be not only better than we all expect
affected but it actually goes so far as
to say that this trailer was really
really good if the show itself can
actually live up to what is being shown
right here then I do think that new and
old fans like me alike will have a
really good time watching it so make
sure to subscribe if you don't want to
miss my breakdown of everything once the
show actually drops on August 31st
thanks for listening to my thoughts I
see you in the next one